dudes you guys are gonna go back in time
yeah
you are going to have a most excellent
adventure through history
really cool that like bill and ted the
positivity that they have and
you know when i meet people who who have
seen the films and like them you know
it's like they say bill and ted and they
smile
right you know it just kind of you know
there's some light that comes from these
characters and it's
it's cool to be a part of that
what strange things are afoot at the
circle
k chris and i came up with the
characters of bill and ted in an
improv group that was formed solely for
the purpose of
us all just pushing ourselves
comedically we rented a stage
in hollywood one night a week
never had an audience and we would just
screw around
to try to do improv exercises or come up
with sketches
and one random day a few months in in
early 83
chris suggested hey what if we do guys
who know nothing about history studying
about history
and one of us was ted one of us was bill
and we just started going with it and
about a year later we thought let's put
him into a little seven minute sketch in
a
in a compilation of sketches and then it
was uh chris's dad
who when chris was talking about this
idea said
they sound like they could be in their
own movie why don't you do that and we
thought
hey yeah why don't we do that so that's
how it happened well the way i landed
this role
going all the way back was through an
extremely long
and arduous audition process that was
unlike anything i had experienced even
though i had been acting
or by then for quite a long time
thankfully i met keanu really early on
and uh we sort of soldiered through it
together
um and didn't expect necessarily to be
cast but that was kind of the happy
by-product of all of that that labor
but it was also a really fun experience
yeah when we went through the audition
process
uh they had all of the artists who were
auditioning playing both roles
um and so i guess when
i i remember that i went there thinking
that i was playing bill but then i was
told i was playing
ted and uh
ultimately i i was okay with that i
didn't i didn't turn around and say i'm
not
doing this movie
the history of bill and ted getting made
is the same in the first movie as it
doesn't face the music
meaning it was hard we wrote bill and
ted as a spec script
it got us fired from our agents that
were representing us
because they hated it so much a young
agent that we had known for a couple
years or i had met a couple years
earlier read it and he liked it
he got set up at warner brothers
actually we did a series of rewrites for
warner brothers
almost every one of which almost made it
way worse
and then we would return back to kind of
what we had initially thought we were
going to be doing in the first place
but finally warner brothers put it in
turn around it got picked up by
dilaurentis
who financed it and then went bankrupt i
believe and then the movie sat on a
shelf for a year then nelson
entertainment picked it up
and finally in 1989 it got released
you have sunk my battleship
excellent yeah
bogus journey had a very interesting uh
creative
um path you know it was the first time
that bill and ted
ended up playing different versions of
themselves whether it was being dead
or evil robots which was thrilling and
so fun to do
um and then there was this other aspect
of
you know the easter bunny was this idea
of bringing kind of horrors of our past
our childhood fears
and in the process of making the film
it became what it was you know so
there's a little bit of this a little
bit of that
and it all kind of went into this really
incredible rich feast unique meal
probably within weeks of bill and ted's
excellent adventure
opening there was there started to be
discussions of like well we should do a
follow-up and of course
ed and i were we wanted to do a
follow-up there were a couple of takes
and one of them was kind of a repeat
they have to pass basically it's the
next school year and they have to pass
an english report
so in order to pass their english report
they go into
romeo and juliet and they go into
huckleberry finn
and they interact with those characters
it's it ended up being
just time travel with a kind of a little
meta twist on it
and the other idea was well they die
and they go to hell and evil evil robot
versions of them kill them and send them
to hell and they have to
work their way back from hell and that
seemed much funnier
to us that seemed much more as we as we
opened it up it was like funny scenes
seem to present themselves as seance or
the studio wasn't really into it they
were not in favor of that they liked the
other one a lot better
and it ended up being alex and keanu of
course because it always ends up being
alex thinking on you and phil and dead
world
that we got their support and they made
it very very
clear that they didn't they weren't
interested
and they wanted to break new ground i
think they loved the idea of playing
evil versions of bill and ted
i think they liked how kind of strange
and surprising it was and so we got it
made because the guys
the guys were into it it's a strange
movie there's some strange jokes in it
and i think they got through because
it was rushed and to a certain degree
there wasn't just
time for the studio to say that's too
weird what is that even doing in there
and so we got some
very peculiar jokes
when we did villain ted's excellent
adventure and then bogus journey we
actually thought
that was the end of the bill and ted
story we wrote
excellent adventure as essentially
adolescence we were in our early 20s
and bogus journey as young men and i
think for both of us we felt like okay
that's it bill and ted is an expression
of that part of our life
and it wasn't until about 2003 2004
something like that that we started
exploring
what if we did a third movie what would
that movie
be it wasn't until about 2007
that we started talking to alex and
keanu about it i know in press alex and
keanu
over the course of that time we're
starting to get more and more questions
about will there be
ever be another bill in ted movie and
keanu used to say no
no no no and then one interview i don't
remember where it was
he said i i'd be open to that and chris
and i we called each other and said
did you see that do you think it's a
possibility
and in 2007 we went to alex winter's
house uh the four of us to talk about
the possibilities
there was never a different version of
this movie
that was going to be made ex the the
ideas in this movie are the one
that the guys signed off on and we tried
desperately to have made for
the last 10 12 years we knew the end
um from from the beginning we we knew
how how
internally emotionally we felt it had to
end i love the script for face to music
and i think that dean paris so the
director made a really charming
fabulous film you know it's not often
you get to play a role that has the
language
like this and the comedy um you know so
it's it's really fun to get to kind of
spread your
your wings and have this language and
have these
characters and in these kind of uh you
know what's at stake in the films
whether it's unite the world save the
world save reality
i love the dialogue as keanu was talking
about and the
richness of the characters and the
different characters that we get to play
uh that's you know a rare thing to get
to do
um but i really love performing with
keanu it's just an incredibly gratifying
thing to do we have a lot of fun we
laugh a lot but there's a lot of
kind of a very uh sort of instinctive
physicality between the way we work
um and uh that's a rare thing to have
um you know with with someone that
you're acting with so i really enjoy
that and it was really fun
to kind of be back in in that playground
again
uh but you know a lot of thought went
into how we were going to be these guys
at this age and
and not make them cartoon characters not
make them try to feel like
they were clinging to some version of
themselves from the past but
but they had that we were going to bring
all of our life experience to
bill and ted now you know despite the
innocence of these characters and
uh so we worked a lot on that i also
just want to say it's really cool that
like bill and ted the positivity that
they have and
you know when i meet people who who have
seen the films and like them you know
it's like they say bill and ted and they
smile
right you know like it just kind of you
know there's some light that comes from
these characters and it's
it's cool to be a part of that be
excellent
to each other
party on dudes i think the sec
the sentiment of it is really
just be the best person
human you can be and if you do that
then you can party you know that you're
going to be
safe you're going to be supported
you're going to get the gift of
of giving you're going to get the gift
of receiving you're going to get the
gift of sharing
and you know and you know
we're we're just we're just some some
humans on a rock in
space and uh so it's kind of nice to
to kind of promote that idea you know
give it a little
bring it in little group hug
i've always interpreted those two
sayings joined together the way they are
as
as you know bill and ted is really about
friendship which means it's about
community uh which means it's about sort
of the interconnectedness of people
and and being compassionate about that
interconnectedness and
and uh i think for me the bill and ted
has always been about
uh you know being compassionate to your
fellows but also engaging with life
that's what the party on part has always
meant to me of just like
you know you can be compassionate and
still just live in isolation or just not
you know and this is really like
bill and said are always like going out
and onto these adventures with like
optimism and hope and
positivity and so i think it's like you
know be kind to your fellow man but
engage with the world like be out in the
world
um that's a really cool message i think
get out of your own head stop thinking
only of yourself
try to think of others they matter as
much as you do
their lives matter as much as yours and
try to understand they're coming from
some place
and they have their own inner lives and
this is all aspirational by the way i
don't actually do this very much in real
life but
in terms of what it theoretically means
this is this is this is what it means to
me try try to try to make other people
happy when possible
well i agree with chris the phrase be
excellent to each other is
aspirational it's an aspirational way to
live it's not it's impossible to do it
all the time
but i think when you get into the
headspace of bill and ted that's their
mentality and it's just
a better place to be and so for me it's
just
like as a mantra a nice place to to
try to start my day from if i can do it
it's a great way to live but truly
that's why playing the characters is so
fun because you're in a headspace
that's really a fun place to be and
that's why they're fun to write
and i think that's why they're fun for
alex and keanu to
to play why it isn't a wild stallion
let's rock
be excellent to each other and party on
[Music]
dudes
[Music]
you